hey man what's going on it's Bill Burrus
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
and ah
just checking in on you just checking in
to see how the [__] you're doing how
your weeks going
I was kidding who I'm just here to run
my [__] mouth
for whatever the hell you're doing right
now what are you huh where are you
you're going to the gym I don't want to
go to the [__] gym that's a normal
thought
no one wants to go to the gym right you
want to sit on the couch order a pizza
side order of cupcakes a little [__]
Heron right
you want to have a grand old [__]
time
you know I don't be sacrilegious here
but what kind of an [__] is God that
he made pizza cupcakes and heroin bad
for you
couldn't just make it easy could he nope
couldn't do it he's always been big on
the diet huh but so [__] funny
is it's like he's like don't eat the
apple which is actually good for you and
then he sends us out of paradise
you know because the second you tell
abroad not to do something as she
[__] goes
sorry I know a bunch of pedophiles wrote
that story and they had issues with you
know
women with hair around their privates
hey I didn't write the story they did
okay
um
anyway uh Jace where do you go from
there you can't eat don't eat the
[__] Apple which is actually good for
you yosuke can stay in Paradise then you
gotta actually have yourself a healthy
thing that he banishes out and then when
we go out here it's like maybe that's
part of the hell is that what it is it's
so [__] stupid
you know
but I have to be honest with you when
you really look at all this [__] that's
happened in the last five years blaming
everything wrong in the world on White
on a white woman is you know
kind of tracks
that's my goal people to be able to
laugh without hacking
ever since I've had pneumonia I haven't
been able to do it I got over the
pneumonia but that has lingered
probably because once I was cured of
pneumonia I went back to smoking cigars
stupid so um
I'm on it though dude I'm on it I got
them all stacked up next time I go over
to The Comedy Store
I got like 20 25
68 cigars I don't know how many I got uh
I'm gonna do a big dump
and not take a [__] I'm dumping the
cigars off I'm getting them out of my
life
all right not a hundred percent though
I'm gonna be that [__] guy man
I'm gonna be that guy that can have the
occasional cigar
oh half a line of cocaine just in case
there's [__] fentanyl in it right I'm
gonna be that guy no
I never mess with the toot as I used to
call it
riding the rail right
um
the [__] else did they say back then oh
he's riding the rail this weekend
the [__] are there was another one too
it was sort of unique to my area I don't
[__] know all I know is my generation
was told that Len Bias took cocaine one
time and died
and then the Lakers could win
back-to-back championships as opposed
you know I swear to God if Larry Bird
didn't blacktop his own [__] driveway
and Len Bias didn't overdose on cocaine
I mean
first of all the Detroit Pistons would
not even exist
[Laughter]
would have been sayonara to them no
matter how much they took your legs out
when you left the floor
um
one of the most overrated teams of all
time the Detroit Pistons oh yeah I'm
coming for you today
89.90 whatever the [__] they were 88 89
was 88 was it what is it 91 92 93 was
the Bulls 94.95 is Houston 96 97 8 Balls
yeah so it was 89.90 was the Pistons
um I'm [__] with you I know it was a
great team but like their their whole
[__] with now they're like sitting
there acting like they're rubbing their
chins and like yeah man we were playing
this we were playing a mind game man nah
no you weren't you were waiting for guys
to leave their feet and you were taking
them out
so the best player landed on his [__]
head and then you didn't have to deal
with them because who's kidding who you
weren't better
I've never respected that kind of play
where it's just like you guys are better
than us so now what we're going to do is
deliberately injure your best players
and beat you down to our level
and uh you know and then the announcers
always say I'll tell you
no I wouldn't no I wouldn't
so sorry
I'm drinking a protein smoothie you're
not getting enough protein
you're cutting right now so you need to
feed your muscles
I've been doing a great thing though
I've been staying away from the [__]
sugar
I don't even I don't even [__] with it
the other night
you know I go to this place uh
uh where they sell all the balloons and
all of that crap my daughter loves
balloons and for whatever reason they
have like movie candy there
right and it's like [__]
you can get five boxes like the big
movie size for a dollar a whack if you
get five of them
so we were gonna go see Fatso right the
whale
and uh that's why I go and I get that
[__] right
and I just ate a bunch of it and I it
was amazing like I kind of took the ride
with the main character
like the self-loathing and then you
start crashing and then I was binging
again I mean it's such a [__] drug
um I was experiencing that that movie on
two levels it was like interactive you
know like they try to do that with that
that movie with the [__] stretched
out blue people whatever that movie is
and for whatever [__] reason they
decided to make another one
you know I look how they waited like
almost 20 years like it was [__] Star
Wars you know
the [__] is it's like Blue Man Group in
outer space whatever they called The
Smurfs
with giantism
um I just remember the first one I was
rooting for the Army
it was weirding me out
it was weirded me out I'll be honest
with you I got weirded out when I saw
the first one and then also like I knew
it was what wasn't going to be good so I
went with all of like the bells and
whistles like you wear the 3D glasses
and you [__] seat shakes you know
some ushers behind you slapping you in
the head like every [__] thing they
could possibly do to make that thing and
I just sat there I was like I could give
a [__] [__]
about these things there's the thing if
they were actually real if we actually
you know the day they actually cast why
aren't real martians playing Martians
we need real aliens to play Aliens
be funny if Donald Trump was casting
that then he would just get a bunch of
illegals that came in from the Mexican
border
that's what that's that's what the
Liberals wanted
this is the greatest movie ever cat I'm
the greatest casting director ever
um
but uh the Oscars said this Sunday
and uh I saw oh my God I keep forgetting
the name of this [__] movie I saw and
I absolutely loved it oh wait a second
wait a second
what happened
oh I see
that's my personal trainer oh yeah soak
that in that's how Hollywood I am now I
have a personal trainer and for the
longest time I was like I'm not [__]
doing I don't need a [__] personal
trainer
all right I've been going to the gym
since 1985. I know what you do
you walk in there you do your arms in a
circle a couple of times you do a couple
of Twisties at the waist some jumping
jacks
and then you walk over there with your
Larry Bird shorts the towel around your
neck tucked in
to you to your [__] Rocky sweatshirt
that you cut the hood off
maybe the sleeves too Bill Belichick
style right
and what do you do you bench press every
[__] time
that's all it was about
does anybody even say that anymore
that was a big [__] deal what are you
benching that was my favorite line in
Boogie Nights
what do you bench
they had that line too in um
what did I just say was called Moon Dogs
wasn't Moon Dogs the [__] did that come
from
the Moon Dogs they were a wrestling crew
why the [__] am I thinking Moon
it's like that that one that made Ben
Affleck and Damon a star
in Robin Williams you know the one
breaks into the cars she gets the fight
Cole Hauser
Goodwill honey
Moon dogs what the [__] was
um
um wait a second
I'll figure that out later why that came
to me like that anyway
when they were when Damon Matt Damon's
character was asking Robin Williams
character what he benched and and Robin
Williams character said he benched 260.
that took me out of the out of the
[__] movie that woke up some muscle
memory from the 80s I would say this
[__] guy did [__] 260. yeah why
don't you go down to [__] goals and
do it
see it
[__] 260 160 maybe on a [__] good
day huh
you [__] bearded [__]
260.
that was definitely improvised
um although you know
Robin had those [__] hairy forearms
he had those pop life he played Popeye
you never know those shorter guys though
they could always bench more because it
was a shorter distance that's what I was
always told or like doing pull-ups
that's what's amazing about zidane
ochara the guy can bang out like 40
pull-ups and he's eight feet tall
can you imagine when he was back in his
home country whatever the [__] he was
from right
Czechoslovakia Prague maybe he was
walking around Prague
he's probably hanging off a [__]
bridge at 15. couldn't put a pull-up bar
High Enough
in his apartment out there in Prague
you know Eastern Europe is with those
[__] buildings they look like they're
gonna fall down but they're not you know
those [__] angled stairways
I'm just [__] with you guys this is
what this is this is an old school thing
that I do is I trash cities that I'm
going to
um
I've got to be going to Prague later on
this year
on that sorry just a little internal
burp there
on um I got a European tour coming up
that's going to begin in Prague
and it's going to end in Athens Greece
you know
I don't know when we're going to
announce it but I'm announcing it now I
don't know why you can't announce it
maybe because I'm institutionalized for
all these years working with Netflix
Netflix always says don't say what
you're doing until we tell you when to
say it what it is that you're doing
um
so yeah it's going to be a nice Fun Run
through Europe and uh I am very excited
about that and some other dates and some
of my shows went on pre-sale uh ticket
sales were were amazing so thank you to
everybody that bought tickets oh
freckles gets to again this year not
have a real job which really was the
goal a lot of people get into this
business because they have this creative
thing they just have to get out of them
I remember hearing the story of Michael
Jackson one time he was in he was in the
studio and he was he was uh he was
recording one of his big hits who can it
be
that was him right and um
at the end of the track he had to run
out into the hall and and dance it out
of him whatever feeling he had now that
that's a [__] artist
okay you can have that in this business
when he wasn't riding that little
choo-choo train around his property that
right there
or climbing trees with eight-year-olds
that was a [__]
that was an artist and then you can have
all the way down to me
all right who's a guy who tried out the
real world
oh I did I packed a lunch I went to that
building every [__] Monday through
Friday for a couple of [__] years I
tried
you know I tried Blue Collar jobs I
sucked at that I like the vibe better
you know because you you sort of weren't
sitting at a desk
um I tried the suit and tie thing I
tried them all I tried sales
I I was a dental assistant I got
certified to take X-rays I got my
license to sell health insurance oh I
did it all I tried
and I was like I I don't like this is
work I don't want to [__] do this
I don't want to do this so that's the
only reason why I do stand-up comedy
it's not because I like comedy
I just don't want to go to the same
[__] building that's what I kind of
liked about sales my favorite part about
sales was not selling somebody it was
the in-between part was driving to the
the next appointment when it was the
middle of the work day and I was out
driving around that was my that was
always my favorite part I had a job
washing windows
you know on like houses and stuff like
that your [__] fingers would go numb
with those those storm windows
some old lady would finally get her
[__] windows wash for the first time
since the [__] Korean conflict and
you'd be sitting there trying to get
them going like your index fingers you
had to switch by the end of the day you
were out of fingers you're down to your
pinky he's trying to get them going you
know you're using two fingers
um
sounding vaguely graphic talking about
opening Windows you [__] perverts so
uh
my favorite part of that job was driving
between each job
one like it was that we had it over the
summer it was a summer day my buddy had
this great he had a Ford F-150
four-wheel drive brand new like an 88
in that iconic silver and I thought that
truck was [__]
gorgeous
always wanted one of those you know it's
funny I ordered
I ordered an F-250 last summer hey
[__] Ford Motor Company when are you
gonna have the robots take 11 minutes
out of their day and slap that thing
together so I could drive around town
and act like I know how to fix things
I'm dressing the part two I'm gonna get
a flannel I'm gonna buy I'm gonna go to
a I'm gonna go to a [__] uh uh what
like what's those smelly stores with the
old clothes
vintage store right oh my God you can
literally smell the people that died in
those clothes
although I will tell you
I went into one of those the other day
because my wife wanted oh let's go in
there there you go they have all cute
things in there and I go in there like
oh my God can how can't you smell
somebody's dead grandmother in here
it's the combination of the smell and
then you go up to the register and they
literally have brooches
oh is there anything creepier than
Estate Jewelry I always just picture the
swollen knuckled finger that they pulled
the ring off of when they came over
there the person had been dead for four
days and the cat was eating her face
because it was no more [__] cat food
around sorry
that's what I think about when I go into
a vintage store
other people go in there and they're
like hey man you know what I'm gonna
dress like the lead guitarist in an
English an underrated English rock band
from the 80s that's what they and they
go in there and they sort of get a coat
that's
kind of a World War One German code but
not really you can also throw it over a
suit you know
or you get some suspenders and some
leather pants and no shirt and then you
throw the [__]
the Nazi Overcoat over you you know and
then you got to have a nipple ring to
tie the whole thing together that was
that was a big you know
and then of a poor excuse for a [__]
uh mohawk
and some of those uh Seattle uh what
were they the uh now rickenbacher what
were those [__] boots that everybody
had with the stitching on the side you
know the ones
the ones that comics comics used to wear
when I when I moved to New York Comics
who wore those those [__] shoes
whatever they were they didn't like
Comics that had high energy
they thought that we were hacks
performers because they were writers and
they would come out there in their shoes
with the stitching down the side and
they would just stand there and do their
jokes and they would kill but they
wouldn't kill like a performer and it
always bugged them because their jokes
were better than our jokes and they knew
it you know but we were up there
like [__] uh Tony Robbins you know
with a headset
selling the [__] out of our [__]
sweating screaming falling down doing
whatever the [__] we had to do
why because we wanted to make you laugh
and make you forget about your troubles
no
because we didn't want to go back to the
real world
anyway
I am coughing less
oh Jesus
um
anyway I watched the Celtics yesterday
beat the [__] out of the Portland
Trailblazers Portland Trail Blazers have
not won the NBA Championship I believe
since 1977 which I also believe was the
last year Led Zeppelin toured the United
States of America
in other words what I'm saying is is
there in a bit of a drought
46 [__] years
those guys like what did they do what
did they [__] that's like some
Poltergeist [__] like I don't know what
they built their Stadium on
but
um
the amount of talented people that they
drafted and then they just get these
inexplicable [__] injuries
like Sam Bowie was unbelievable
was it Kansas was he a Kentucky one of
those K schools
um
every kiss begins with k over those
[__] cars those Band-Aid colored cars
that those chicks used to drive around
Mary Kay cosmetics there's another job I
would have tried out
if I didn't become a comedian
all right and I wouldn't enjoy selling
Rouge to a [__] 84 year old what I
would enjoy would be the drive over to
the person's house
oh my God
I would [__] spray perfect I would
put perfume right in my mustache before
I walked in there so I wouldn't smell
her impending death of that you know
when you walk in you know
I guess none of you guys had a paper
route's like an old that's like a
[__] churn and butter kind of job I
used to have I had a paper from third
grade until ninth grade
and I remember you knew what customers
were gonna die
on your paper route
you just knew when you walked into the
house you know or if you walked into the
house and everybody was young but you
smelt death they were like all right
their Nana's in the basement or it's up
in the attic one of the other one or the
other they got they got somebody moved
in
either their grandfather or grandmother
died and then the other one moved in and
they're downstairs and they've begun the
process of dying I can smell it
please pay me and get me the [__] out of
here this is this is killing and they
would always have the heat cranked when
you had a dying relative in your house I
don't care if it was July they had the
[__] heat on
Oh Billy do you want to come in no
that's good that's I'm good I'm good out
here how about it's raining I like the
rain
shines up my freckles
um
Annie who
uh let me see I saw this movie
let me let me see
I figured I I you know the the it was
just too difficult to say the Banshees
of Innis Sharon I hope I'm saying it
right
um
I watched that the other night with Nia
and just absolutely
[__] love that movie Colin Farrell
and Brendan Gleason are incredible and
then there's this other kid in there
Barry I'm gonna say it wrong Keogan or
whatever absolutely blew me away Kerry
Condon
play in the sister
um
that's that's kind of an instant classic
one of those ones I'm just going to go
back to when I'm in that kind of mood
where um I don't know watch the movie
I'm not gonna say what it was about but
uh
what I love about the two main
characters is I've been both of them
uh at some point in my life not to the
extreme
that Brendan Gleason goes to but like
definitely uh
it's about a friendship that's kind of
um
got to a difficult place
so yeah so I watched the uh was I was
talking about the Portland Trailblazers
and then they got uh Greg Oden
who is just Unstoppable at Ohio State
Big Ten legit basketball you know
and then they [__] draft him and he
had like some [__] like microscopic
fracture of his knee they paid him all
of this money could have picked him or
Kevin Durant
let me see what the draft oh these are
always great these this is like the
worst thing a sports fan can do
is is go and they look up NBA
draft
Greg
Odin
to Greg Odin is just he's only 34
[__] years old 35 years old
unbelievable all right Greg Odin
Kevin Durant that was the big thing that
you who you gonna pick
in the Seattle SuperSonics at that point
were called the Seattle Sonics
all right the 2007 NBA draft
let's see it went as fault this is the
worst thing you can do as a sports fan
because anybody why the [__] did they
take
when this guy
just got draft selections
number one Greg Oden was selected first
overall by the Portland Trailblazers but
was plagued with knee injuries and
retired after seven seasons
um I mean he was a [__] man child
the career that kid would have had
Kevin Durant was selected second by the
Seattle SuperSonics and is considered to
be one of the greatest scorers of all
time winning the 2014 MVP back-to-back
final and finals MVPs in 2017 and 18. I
didn't know he got the finals MVP Al
Horford
what a [__] draft was selected third
overall by the Atlanta Hawks and has
been named to five all-star teams he's
going to get a championship this year
hopefully Mike Conley
uh selected fourth oh Joakim Noah
when the [__] did that guy not show up
to ball
answer never every night Marc Gasol
Powell's brother
this is what kills me is this what is it
like two rounds of the NBA draft this is
the hardest [__] sport to make it in
there's two rounds
60 people get drafted
that's it
think about that there's 64 teams
in March Madness in the tournament every
year so that means there's like four
entire teams that won't get drafted
if they took one player we can do simple
math we can do simple math don't talk
down to us
ouch you talk down to me with your
simple math
I want you just a [__] high thread
count [__] I really want to get that
going oh hello [__]
hairy High thread count that's not a
good one that's a high thread count
It's just tough that's why that never
that never stuck
Theodore thread count
Teddy thread count
uh
I'm gonna let that go it'll come to me
um all right I'm gonna read a little bit
of advertising
I should say I'm going to read a little
bit of advertising I'm not going to read
a little oh look at that picture
where'd the other one go that was when I
took my daughter to her first and only
Red Sox game
airplanes over the years
off we go you know I went to um
I did a nice flight the other day man
this is the time of year to go fly when
it's rained like that this year I'm
telling you I was talking to this guy
the other day I went to uh
my daughter went to a birthday party I
was talking to the dad
and he was going like yeah it looks like
Ireland out here Portland Oregon it's
amazing
and I was flying out
um
this is fun time to go out too over like
the ocean because the whales ah the
whales they're starting to migrate
whatever the [__] they're doing I've
only seen one ever
look like a glow stick because it was
like noon and it was uh really sunny out
and it was just below the surface and
the sun glistening glistening off of it
that's all it didn't look like a whale I
was kind of disappointed I was like do
some whale [__] you know bring your tail
up and smash somebody's little boat
there's another thing too Hollywood has
a lot of balls
you know when you look at the casting
casting what did I say like that
the way they [__] wagged I'll never
get over that the way they wag their
finger about social [__] issues the
[__] that they've done with animals the
stereotypes that they've done with them
I just watched Serpico the other night
with some buddies my God
[__] amazing movie but the roles that
black people have in it there was a well
first woman she's getting raped by like
three black dudes uh everybody like we
were actually we got like three quarters
of the movie I'm like that is literally
the first black guy that has not got
that I've seen this movie that was not
doing something illegal and then got
arrested
and then all these years later they're
like hey red States why don't you get it
together like we have it together
um you ever think that maybe a lot of
the ways that they think about those
people was because of the movies that
you [__] liberal [__] made you ever
think about that ah look at me trying to
make points all right Simply Safe
you know if you're a regular listener
you know what my age regular means
something else but I I still have a
young brain I know what they're talking
about here you know I always recommend
Simply Safe home security and I'm not
the only one
and I'm not the only one
what was that you may say I recommend
Simply Safe home security but
I'm not the only one there it is
U.S news recently named Simply Safe the
best home security system of 2023.
sorry it was a tribute to [__] Yoko
and C C Net recently awarded I'm sorry
if actually come to yokos
[Applause]
by the way if I ever told you how much
my neighbors hate me and CNET recently
awarded them their editor's choice for
home security they are main there are
many reasons why Simply Safe is trusted
by experts and customers alike
SimpliSafe is designed with Cutting Edge
technology in backed by 24 7
Professional monitoring in an emergency
in an emergency use fast project protect
technology only from SimpliSafe to
capture critical evidence and verify the
threat is real so you can get priority
police dispatch
um 24 7 Professional monitoring service
costs under one dollar a day less than
half the price of traditional home
security systems you can lock and unlock
your doors access your camera in arm and
disarm your system from anywhere
you could be in [__] Prague on some
crooked stairs locked unlocked locked
unlocked you can do whatever you want
you can watch the guy come up the walk
you unlock it huh can you make it can
you make it oh locked what happened I
don't know if you can do that uh CNET
name Simply Safe editor's choice for
2023. customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com
go today
and claim a free indoor security camera
plus 20 off your order and interactive
monitoring that's simplysafe.com
[Music]
there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
yeah I'm telling you man I have the best
pause
in podcast advertising reading I'll
[__] go up with any of them
I'll go up against the big dogs doesn't
bother me
um
hey so my son's a little over two and a
half now so he's old enough and I I take
him [__] everywhere now it's my
favorite thing to do
um
it's just the best and I got that idea
from the late great David Richardson one
of our writers on F is for family and
when I was having a boy he he was
telling me he goes oh he goes I used to
take my son everywhere I took him
everywhere and I just always stuck with
me I was thinking like man what a great
dad that's a great dad thing to do and I
immediately started doing it with my
daughter because I never took my
daughter anyway because she was my first
and I was just like I mean the paranoia
that I [__] had I remember sitting
out on the front porch with her
you know sit I got an old man rocking
chair you know you got to do it people
just don't fight aging just do it okay
get yourself a little button-up sweater
in a pipe in a rocking chair so I'm
sitting there I'm on this rocking chair
and I second I got out there and I sat
in that chair
you know finally became a dad so late in
life and I couldn't believe it Overjoyed
overflowed with love the second I sat
down the immediate the first thing I
thought of was a bird of prey swooping
in and trying to grab my daughter and I
pictured ripping the thing's legs off
and stabbing it to death with its own
talents and like do you remember when
that [__] Nazi was stabbing that that
Jewish army guy there and uh Saving
Private Ryan and he was talking to him
before he did it that's what I was going
to do to the bird
so needless to say I didn't take her
anywhere until
uh David Richardson who I I missed
tremendously
um
one of the darkest senses of humor of
anybody I've ever met
uh him and Mark Wilmore what a massive
losses to Comedy um anyways that's a sad
way
sad way to end but I am thinking about
death lately because uh
uh my friend Diana passed away
um
unreal every time I stretch now and roll
out I I just I'll I'll never not think
of her if you didn't listen to my last
podcast she was my 75 year old masseuse
Jedi masseuse that got rid of my sciatic
nerve problems frozen shoulder rotator
cuff things my back was like Twisted you
know I was all [__] up from lifting in
the 80s
um
I was actually talking to a buddy of
mine who actually introduced me to her
and we were laughing and I was saying
about her I was like you know if you
lined up everybody that she helped in
life and everybody that she told off
because she didn't take [__] from
anybody like both lines would disappear
over the horizon
she was [__] hilarious and uh one of
the truly just great people I've ever
met in my life so once again I'm still
eulogizing her rest her soul all right
so that's the podcast please enjoy the
music that the great Andrew femalis
picks out
and then we'll have a bonus episode of
the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast after this
I hope you guys have a great day and a
wonderful weekend
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrd it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
March 9th
2015 how's it going how are you
um
Oh Billy bloodbath was [__] sick as a
goddamn dog
I think all of the World Travel caught
up to me I had a sore throat I think I
got a bad case of [__] sauce
you know I was over there in Southeast
Asia
you know what I mean you gotta love the
Asians the second they start getting
sick what do they do they walk around
coughing all over everybody like they do
here in America [__] no they go out and
they get themselves a surgical mask
God knows they're so goddamn smart half
of them are probably in medical school
so they probably get them free at charge
but still
still considerate right
I don't know maybe I [__] walk by
somebody over there that wasn't wearing
one who should have been like the one
inconsiderate person in Hong Kong or
Singapore or something all like they're
not the reality was is I went through
all
Jesus this is like the best I've felt in
three days
and I know what you guys going to say oh
you know what it is Bill it's just
cigars well [__] you
I don't need to hear from you
Leonard Nimoy
sent a tweet on his [__] death bed
that changed my world all right
I'm done with the [__] I'm not done with
them but I'm done with them
all right I haven't smoked in uh
what two weeks
oh yeah why are you being so [__] all
right it's good that's good for me it's
good for me
you know
two weeks without a Stog
16 days I've gone and uh I'm good man
I'm not gonna smoke one until I do that
the bus tour when I go down south man go
down there and then [__] Swamp People
lay down there what are they doing
they're down there wrestling an
alligator
boy what you doing
I see what you're doing it was
rhetorical question why don't you go
weight out into the swamp and see what
you can catch with your foot drag it
back on the beach and I'll shoot it with
shotgun mom over there throwing a pot
what do you think huh what do you think
huh
thank you
that little skit was called the other
white people
you know what I mean
when they're always trying to act like
white people all evil running Banks you
know just remember some of them are in
swamps shooting varmints so they can eat
that night that's what I learned this
week when I just sat I sat and fed I
laid in bed
from [__] Thursday
right through to yesterday Sunday I just
stayed in bed
I [__] canceled everything
I was just you know canceled shows
you know I was supposed to go on a
picnic I said I can't do that you know
which really upset things because not
only was I bringing the basket I was
also bringing a tablecloth so
my apologies
I'm kidding I didn't have a picnic
you know I'm thinking of a picnic
because I I
saw this thing Louis Vuitton makes they
actually make this [__] little bar
this portable bar this is when you know
you're a booze hound you know
your wife's looking at some [__] you
know whatever the [__] they look at in
those stores and you're like just
thumbing through the catalog going look
at this overpriced [__] right then
all of a sudden you go oh wait a minute
they got a bar
and you can bring it with you
like that's like some old school [__]
before Mothers Against drinking and
driving before drinking and driving was
even a problem first of all back in the
day it's like how many people even had
cars right
you know
there's barely any [__] roads
and they were all pretty much straight
went right from The Farmhouse right to
downtown right there wasn't a problem
you made your booze at home anyways
right in your bathtub don't worry it
wasn't a problem
so that was the thing you had to bring
your booze from home over to somebody
else's I just I don't know
I don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about but I laid in bed for uh
um I don't know Thursday Friday Saturday
and running to Sunday and I watched a
bunch of sports
and I watched a bunch of [__] movies
all from like the middle of the movie
like I saw
the middle of the Seth Rogen Neighbors
movie
I saw that just about right after they
had moved the kids and moved in to the
end of the movie
then I flipped over I kept missing like
the first 20 minutes of every movie I
saw the Vince Vaughn Owen Wilson
I don't know what happened somehow they
ended up at this computer company
I saw that one
uh oh and then I watched that whole
[__] that Robert Durst jinxed
has anybody even watching that it's
about this [__] Rich dude
right
this Rich fella who uh he's just jinxed
like everywhere he goes like somebody
dies it's like Murder She Wrote except
this person's always the suspect that
was like the old joke with like Murder
She Wrote like everywhere that woman
went there was always a murder but she
was never a suspect well this guy
everywhere he went there was a murder
and he was always the suspect
I mean this poor bastard you know
somebody was always getting murdered
in his vicinity
and they kept trying to pin it on him
and they couldn't do it like his first
wife his first wife he said I took her
down the train station and that's the
last time I ever saw
that was like 30 years ago
they never able to pin that on him he
had some brought out in Cali
living in L.A
they have them in the state of
California
but he flew into Northern California way
up North like near Eureka
and so all they can do is put them in
the state which is like saying you know
there was a murder in South Carolina uh
yeah well I was in Massachusetts I mean
that's how long the [__] state is and
then the last one was uh he had a tenant
and that one he actually admitted to
killing but he said it was in
self-defense and he chopped up the body
because he didn't think anybody was
going to believe him
um you got to see this thing and just
the way the guy talks
he sounds like the guy who does the
voice over
on the Cadbury egg commercials
because when he's gone they are gone he
sounded just like that like he would
just be going like I never
knowingly lied
I never I never
purposefully
I never purposely lied
about anything I mean
telling the whole truth I mean nobody
tells the whole truth but I never lied I
mean should did I leave things out
you know you ask just if if I leave this
out
because
it won't be not the truth but
if I'm worried of how it will be
interpreted that it could actually hurt
me then yes you leave it out but I never
purposely knowingly lied you got to see
this guy
and the more you watch this I mean right
off the bat you like this [__] guy
did this [__] and the more you watch it
you're just like you don't go in the
other direction you're like this guy
this guy really did this [__] this guy
without a doubt how is this guy walking
oh that's right he sees filthy stinking
rich
I watched that and I watched [__]
people down in a swamp shooting Gators
this kid all nervous wanting to wrestle
his first alligator and I thought I was
like Jesus Christ he's going to get in
the water with this [__] thing and
all it meant was when they got one on
the line trying to pull it into the boat
without having that thing pull you over
pull you under
while your uncle sits there with the
shotgun go and hold him still and then
they [__] blow its head off
I mean what do you do with it I mean
you're sitting there like you got to
shoot an alligator in the face I mean
you got to think like his belly alone
you get those large scales of some shoes
I mean there's pimps out there they'll
pay 12 Grand a pair
right
walk it over to Tom Ford
um
I never knowingly I'm gonna I'm gonna
use that with my wife one time right
when she sits there giving me [__] about
something
you know you said you're gonna be home
at two it's four in the morning the hell
it shouldn't be like look I never
purposely knowingly lied about when I
was gonna come home to you
did I leave out some of the truths about
buying the last 14 rounds I mean nobody
tells the whole truth
um
anyways so uh what else did I watch I
watched Carolina Duke
duke duke duke or I watch that [__] and
just sat there enjoying that rivalry and
whenever I watched Duke Carolina or any
big like college football game
is anybody else like this like don't you
did you ever just wish like man I wish I
studied
you know I wish I studied in high school
and actually got into a good college so
I could follow a [__] you know
like the college I went to I had no
[__] Sports programs there's no way
to follow
there's no way to follow what do I do
you know what I mean
if you [__] go to Ohio State like any
[__]
mouth breathing jerk off
in in in the state of Ohio it's a
[__] state school you can get in
there University of Michigan just to be
fair with that rivalry if you if you
could be living in a goddamn [__] cow
patch on the Upper Peninsula of Michigan
you can go to the University of Michigan
all you got to do is I don't know what
you got to do [__] you know have like
a [__] b-minus average Maybe
and come stumbling out of that campus
campus with your [__] uh
blue and Maze Poncho when you're in the
game
that little bus City they got there this
[__] campus is so big they got buses
and [__] they got all these [__]
schools well you don't even have to be
that smart to get into like USC there's
another one
if you just show up with a tan line you
get in at the school and then for the
rest of your [__] life
you get this you get to kind of still be
connected and root for the old team
you know put on your raccoon [__]
floor-length coat
whatever the [__] they do call a Statue
of Liberty play
you get to [__] hang in there
[__] it what the hell was I thinking
why didn't I study well I never
purposely
didn't study
or lie to my teachers
um
no [__] kills me
kills me that my adopted school is LSU
right
like that's that's one of those schools
that like you know
basically if you just have teeth They're
Gonna Let You in if you're in [__]
Louisiana
and you know I know this is offending a
lot of people but the truth hurts those
giant [__] schools
they have so many buildings
they have so much real estate the
[__] the overhead they have just to
keep that just to keep the grass mowed
anything with a pulse that's from that
state that's walking in they're taking
you money they don't give a [__]
go ahead go go buy a goddamn
[__] go Tigers t-shirt don't go
[__] do that and then then they they
give it to the out of state people like
I actually would have been smart
as an out-of-state student to get into
LSU
all right but if if I lived in Louisiana
all right
if I was down there in the swamp right
down there in the marsh
you know what I mean my [__] jeans
all rolled up mid-calf
down there trying to get some
Sidewinders and some [__] crawfish
whatever they do down there I mean you
know you don't have time to [__]
learn how to read
in a [__] State like Louisiana I mean
come on well Alabama University of
Alabama I mean in Auburn Jesus Christ
they just have this invisible line
they're just trying to get people to
learn how to read even even at the
college level
if you just [__] somewhere you know
they're just trying to get caught up
just so they still recognized as a state
anybody in the northern part you guys
where you guys wear crimson
which is they they think is so like oh
my God a fancy name for the word red
right
they let him go to [__] Alabama and
then any animals left down south they
send them to Auburn that's all it is and
then what they do is when out of state
people show up everybody [__] dresses
up and they put on their saddle shoes
and their [__] sweaters and then they
jack up the prices
you know what I mean because someone
like me I came from a real state
Massachusetts
you know
I'm used to schools like [__] Harvard
and MIT
like that's like that's the high water
mark
of where I'm where my head is at
obviously I'm gonna think
that you have to be smart to go to the
University of Georgia I've never been
there
I don't realize that most of the people
don't have running water in these states
so if I was to show up there I would
just be you know I would have to pay
through the nose so
that's why I never uh I didn't study
when I was in high school because I was
like well there's no way I'm getting
into Harvard there's no way I'm getting
into MIT and every other school you know
here in [__] Massachusetts is just
basically uh
you know let's get [__] faced for four
years essentially right
I gotta pick one of these schools
oh and I went to all I went to like
three different schools in Massachusetts
before I finally finished up right
but I never went out of state because I
I just assumed that you know
you had to be smart to get in those
schools had I know now that I've gone
around I've done stand-up
in most of those schools
and I saw
the the the unbelievable uh the horror
of what is the educational system in
this country I mean
I mean I think I would have studied
what do I would have gone
it was funny if somebody's going to cut
that up and they're going to put it on
some [__] uh
returning sophomore website or whatever
the [__] the incoming freshman thing
[__] sued for uh libel Maybe
and I'll just say it's it's a comedy
podcast it was just jokes I wasn't
knowingly lying about your school
by the way speaking of that type of [__]
getting in trouble for [__] that you say
I got to tell you something right now
watching Kurt Schilling
going after everybody who trolled his
[__] daughter
is one of the greatest things I've ever
seen on the internet
I am I am so
like just loving every second of
watching Kurt showing do that [__]
that's the funniest [__] ever
this I as far as I can tell he's the
first guy that ever
flip the light switch on
and send all the roaches running for the
corners
all those tough talking [__] I mean
you know these people are just [__]
[__] around or whatever and Shillings
going like
you know I know all their names I know
where they live I know where they work
and how he's going to shut him down
and how these tweets are going to follow
them for the rest of their lives it's
like Kurt you're not that important it's
not going to follow them for the rest of
life for their lives okay it's very
current you know
and then it's going to be [__] over
I think it's going to be but I actually
think it's funny
that every once in a while you need that
balance
you know just to keep trolls on their
toes
I think it's funny as [__] hell I
mean God knows comedians get in trouble
for everything every five seconds why
can't trolls
this [__] idiots hey congratulations
they weren't even good jokes either
congratulations my daughter she's going
to be pitching at this school and then
somebody I'm gonna rape her huh tweet
then he loses his job at like [__]
Papa John's
he's sitting there crying in some empty
pizza box it was just a joke man
I can't believe that guy with the
[__] World Series rings
is taking my job man
something the Yankees organization lost
their [__] job I think it's [__]
it's hilarious
you know because they do it to
entertainers all the [__] time
anything we tweet all of a sudden is
taken seriously all of a sudden you
can't go Aflac whatever the [__]
people's jobs were obviously you lose
that million dollar job well good for
you now you lose your [__] uh working
at Starbucks job
I don't know I just think it's funny I
think it would be great I think it would
be great if every once in a while
that happened to trolls
guys I apologize man
[__]
you know what happened
it was when I was really sick I was
cranking the heat like an [__]
and uh not like an [__] going
through the [__] sweats and chills
sweats and chills right it's like I was
kicking heroin or something
and I was cranking the Heat
and then my throat got unbelievably dry
and dry
I never knowingly had to drive through
I'm sorry I must stop doing that
um
and I never attributed to the fact that
was because I was sick and that I was
actually you know I dried out the
[__] air
and uh last night I finally took out the
old uh humidifier
and it changed my goddamn world
and you know something I never would
have thought to do that if I didn't try
to get my pilot's license because I
wouldn't have learned about the weather
and moisture in the air or anything I
never would have understood it it still
would have been Magic
weather always blew my mind
that people could understand what was
going on I'm like it was like air is
invisible that's one of the most that's
what to me that's one of the greatest
accomplishments of human beings is being
able to understand weather
like how to [__]
somebody sat there
and rather just enjoying the breeze had
to figure out why there was a breeze
figured out somehow
that that there was air more dense than
other air
in that high pressure wants to go to low
pressure and when you feel a breeze
that's [__] air moving from one
system to one I would have [__] has time
to figure that out or maybe you're
standing in in a [__]
I don't know
in an alley
and you're getting the [__] uh
Venturi effect like in a carburetor
right
like who had the [__] those [__]
Eggheads you just got you gotta give it
to them
but I gotta tell you we are uh despite
how smart we're too smart for our own
[__] good I I am convinced of that
[__] I gotta tell you that's why that
that [__] fella there you know little
pretzel man there
you know with the computer voice really
annoys the [__] out of me because he's
re the stuff he's predicting is is
pretty basic isn't it
he's basically predicting that we're
going that we're going to be uh
you know we're gonna be we're gonna
hasten our own demise it's just like gee
gee wow how'd you come up with that
because of every [__] thing we've
ever done you jerk off
so [__] say everybody's so [__]
blown away because he's got a computer
voice you know what I mean
they didn't treat Roger at Ebert that
way all of a sudden he didn't know every
[__] thing about movies did he why
are we listening to this guy like he
[__] knows everything you know what
because you feel bad for him
you know maybe he was a [__]
you just don't know it now now he
doesn't have the ability to do it I bet
he was a pompous ass
he's kind of like the original hater
isn't he he's just [__] he's kind of
rather than doing it individually on
Twitter he's [__] doing it to the
whole world
I love how there's people like that it's
just like you know something why don't
you [__] wheel yourself into Vegas
okay and go make and just
[__]
win every goddamn game if you're this
good about the future and [__] why don't
you go bet on some [__] football
games why don't you sit down in a
blackjack table
all right and just bust some Casino out
stop with your [__] oh and your
future tidal waves gonna shut up
guy going around giving speeches
unbelievable
um anyways ah Jesus that's a bad one
that was oh Jesus that was a bad that
you know I'm blaming that last one on
cold medicine
um all right this is this is the uh this
is the Monday Morning podcast here and
um I know it's a little late this
morning but uh like I said I'm trying to
finish up that helicopter [__] and I had
a lesson this morning all right I had to
cancel two last week because I had
whooping cough and I had to go this
morning how did I fly I actually flew
pretty good
I flew over the LA River and when I
looked down I saw this guy in a Segway I
swear to God I think he [__] Juiced
it up
you know having a cough really affects
your timing
all right you know what I need I need a
lodge
is that somebody knocking or is that the
dog Cleo what are you doing
oh my God I'm gonna have to hit [__]
pause
oh I didn't tell you guys this as sick
as I am
[__]
I um
you know one of the things when you're
sick as a man by the time you come out
the other side you have a beard right
there's somebody having a beard
it just makes you feel like you're
homeless right so
I had to shave this thing off I'm gonna
try to talk through the coughs
and um
this is [__] unreal
um
so I go to shave this [__] thing off
I have to pause
all right I'm back Jesus Christ I got
bad
those are gonna cough up a [__] lung
here
so
I'm going to trim this [__] beard off
and I'm trimming the whiskers around my
mouth and my nose is stuffed up because
I have a cold so without realizing that
my mouth was a little bit open it was
breathing through my mouth
and I inhaled
a [__] whisker and it's still in the
back of my throat
it's [__] driving me nuts I've eaten
like half a loaf of [__] bread
I can't get it out of there so right now
when it switches around I already have
the sore throat then I got this [__]
whisker back there
I'm in my own living hell here do you
know last night
I'm laying in bed
I am stop sorry
all right I'm back Jesus [__] Christ
this something happens when I'm [__]
my nose gets stuffed up I stop breathing
through my mouth it dries out my throat
and then that [__] whisker starts
wagging its tail back there
I'm finished
um
so last night I'm laying in bed
and um
and that [__] whiskers driving me
crazy
and I just I just opened my eyes and
said [__] this
like you know that moment and No Country
for Old Men
when uh what's his face decides he's
going to go back and get that dude some
agua
it was like that moment right and I went
upstairs
and I opened up this take out food like
uh utensils
and I took out the knife
right
and then I got some invisible tape
or whatever the [__] you call you know
masking tape you know the [__] [__]
you do to wrap presents with whatever
the [__] it's called tape
and uh I [__] tape up the handle
right and then I just take this [__]
plastic knife with the tape on it and I
just stick it down my throat because my
thing is the tape is going to stick to
the hair
and it's going to pull out
well what ended up happening was I stuck
it down my throat
and uh
once the tape gets wet it doesn't work I
didn't realize that so I kept putting it
down my throat
and as I'm putting it down my throat
just ignoring the gag reflex as it's I'm
going
just doing that right which is also
causing my tongue to become concave
which is making it harder I needed to
[__] stand strong
so I was thinking that that's the reason
why I couldn't get this [__] thing
and uh I finally just mentally was just
like I'm ignoring the gag reflex
and I was able to [__] mind [__] the
gag reflex for a Split Second
and but what the result was I made a
noise that sounded like somebody else
made it it didn't even sound like my own
voice
and it actually made me laugh and then I
puked
and I gotta tell you something
laughs
the [__] hair still back there
I can't get rid of it so
I guess I just got to eat like 90 000
[__] loaves of bread if anybody
has a solution I looked it up on the
internet nobody has a solution
nobody out there nobody knows what the
[__] you're supposed to do all right
um
hey by the way uh I'm gonna read emails
at the end of this if you'd like to send
an email to this podcast the podcast
email is Bill at the mmpodcast.com and
the Twitter is at the mm podcast all
right
yeah all right okay
here we here we go reactions
to last week's email about keeping the
name Isis Bill the overwhelming majority
of people said
uh that that they should keep the name
Isis reasons varied from don't let the
terrorists win to it's a great song
so there you go follow up to the
girlfriend's breath stinks oh remember a
couple weeks ago
this guy met the woman of his dreams and
um
her breath uh is George Carlin would say
uh could knock a buzzard off a [__]
wagon
he had to figure out a nice way to say
that
um
all right bill I here's the follow-up
bill I emailed a few weeks ago a few
weeks back asking you what to do about
my girlfriend's breath your advice as
well as Nia's was taken to heart and put
in action oh Jesus here we go at first I
thought maybe giving her my iPod saying
you have to listen to this and player
the audio of you two talking about what
I should do while I walked away but I
thought better of it oh Jesus Christ
don't do that
you better hope she never [__] hears
any of this
I never even thought of that so [__]
wound up in my own [__]
um
he goes anyways I saw her I sort of just
sat her down told her I loved her very
good
uh she was at that point was going like
all right he's either gonna break up
with me or tell me that he's gay
um look before we go anywhere I just
wanna let you know that I love you you
know [__] here it comes what do you got
a third nipple
um so anyways he says that he loves her
and that I wanted her to go to the
dentist because everyone should
I told her I'd pay for her first visit
and then get her on my dental plan when
I start work fortunately she asks why
does my breath stink or something sort
of with a laugh
like she was except expecting me to say
no
but I kind of raised my eyebrows and
shoulders and smirked a bit oh
he goes wasn't this smoothest way of
doing it and she was a little taken
aback but that was expected
she thanked me for offering to pay and
told me she'd start taking better care
of herself I don't think she can do much
more though because I did see her brush
and floss all the time
should have said that before Clary
clarifying some things anyways hopefully
the dentist finds out what's wrong and
everything turns out all right thanks a
bunch and thanks thank Nia for me too
all right there you go
so
um
what was I going to say that's a good
deal yeah she I remember hearing a story
um
forget what the hell I heard it but
it turned out to be a sinus infection
and it's just something about like
when your breaths just stinks like you
just can't smell it which makes no
[__] sense in every comic in the
world has done a joke that makes no
sense because your nose is right above
your mouth you ought to be smelling it
all the [__] time and you can't
uh well thank god it worked out um I was
actually meaning to read a
advertising here it's probably good that
I read some nice emails after my
previous [__] hacking up along there
all right
all right let's get back to this [__]
here oh by the way I bought a DVD the
other day because I'm old
all right
I'm getting SoundCloud taken off my
computer because I'm bold oh [__] am I
rapping
um I actually am getting it taken off
[__] [__] I go to go into my
[__] phone to play a song that I
always play and all of a sudden it's not
available anymore
there's a little Cloud next to it now oh
is that where you put it oh oh thank you
thank you for solving my [__] full
phone problem without even Consulting me
first you [__] weirdo
I love like they act like they're doing
me a favor
then I had to download something else to
be able to do it and it was actually
going to cost me more money for this
song that I already owned
why don't you just say my phone's your
phone's full
go move some of this [__] to an external
hard drive and then come back you can
download more [__] why don't you just do
that
stop acting like you're doing me a favor
by oh hey I'll hold on to some of your
[__]
I don't know I'm sure some [__] nerd
will tell me that I'm being paranoid but
I don't think I am so anyways I bought
JoJo Mayer's new uh what's not new came
out last year his um his follow-up
to uh secrets of the modern drummer or
whatever the [__] it's called
and uh this is the one he did one a
couple years ago
that was about all these different you
know molar techniques and all that type
of [__]
um Boulder method and all that different
grips and all that [__] because he can
play
at blinding speeds and never get tired
right
because he's using it all efficiently
it's all physics of that [__] so this
guy JoJo mayor has the fastest bass drum
foot I have ever heard in my life
and I know that's saying a lot for a
single bass drum player this guy can do
three four in a row like
I never heard anything like it
blew people away and
it's basically
the same kind of uh
like that push-pull method that you do
with you with with uh with your hand he
does it with his foot and just had the
discipline to sit there and do it and
I saw Steve Gad do something like that
first on his up close video like 30
years ago and JoJo is just taking it to
a whole other level so now he has a DVD
where he breaks it down
in
basically now that that knowledge is out
there and then he showed everybody how
to do it I can't imagine
what this next generation of drummers is
going to just from from day one from the
day one when you sit down to learn drums
like that information is already on
video for you to watch
like this is why like
some of these kids I see every time I
think I'm getting better at drums
there'll be some eight-year-old kid
not even on YouTube because there's
already like you know Prodigy there's
always been kids like that but I'll just
go down to Guitar Center
or whatever there's always some kid in
there
after I played I think I sounded all
right if any other drummer was listening
like some kid will just sit down I'm
like ah you [__]
there's always somebody better so
anyways that's going to be my new
obsession
I mean if you could do half the [__]
that this guy did
you know just being able to play along
to so many of those
songs just growing up that was like oh
my God how's that guy's foot so fast it
will be a joke
like like the fact that this guy rather
than just figuring out this [__] himself
and just hoarding it to himself and not
letting anybody film him the fact that
he just shares it with everybody so
[__] cool and he's like this total
like it's a three DVD thing I mean the
first one was like an hour and a half
long I don't even know how long the
other ones are one of them is just the
entire history of the bass drum itself I
mean this guy is obsessed in a uh in a
great way about the whole thing so I
highly recommend it
um
like I said I was laid up for [__]
three four days and
um
that's all I did was just sit there and
uh
I watched this thing on women in prison
and you're thinking like all right man
this can't be worse than guys
but you know oh my God just you know
they just showed the blood
after a fight that was on the floor
between two and they didn't even have
any weapons
I mean it looked like somebody [__]
gutted a pig
[__] it and I I would never
the only way I could ever survive
in prison was the second I got there
would be to attack a guard
and then survived the beatdown
every time they went to take me out of
the hole I would just attack them again
and then then they finally just decide
that this person cannot be around
anybody else
and then I would slowly go crazy
they'd let me out once a day my vision
would end up being [__] up
you know your eyes actually say keep you
in a Cell long enough that actually
[__] with your vision you lose your
farsighted ability
because you don't use it anymore because
you're [__] looking
you know you can't see beyond
eight feet
isn't that [__] I saw something about
that one time
I can't remember where or maybe somebody
tell me that and they had no scientific
background I have no idea but I'm
presenting it as fact
um
what else uh oh Jesus I'm tapering off
here
oh and I saw a commercial for the new
[__] Cadillac
four-door [__] sedan that's gonna go
200 miles an hour
how [__] great is that
I swear to God
I swear to God I think we're handling
global warming perfectly
just stay the [__] course
and when it all just you know whatever
when the water rises up like it is in
Miami
you know when that happens over the last
bit of Greenland you know whatever we
had a good time we had a good [__]
time we had a nice run
you know
why not 200 mile an hour sedan
phenomenal
um all right let me read a couple more
of these things I apologize for the
weird breathing the sound of my [__]
cough drop but I I'm a plane hurt this
week all right give me a break just be
lucky you can't smell the Vicks Vapor
Rub
all right girlfriend flirting
girlfriend flirting
hello red Billy boy I have a question
for the podcast
um I met a great girl six months ago six
months ago she's a real lady
and she Prides herself on being honest
and loyal
that's a red flag
anybody who says I pride myself on being
honest and loyal I just feel like
they're already [__] uh that's like
Roger Clemens when he used to always do
the workout videos
you know for the local TV look how hard
he works out and you find out he's
[__]
you know Dylan roids or whatever the
[__] he got busted for
here's another one I noticed I watched a
lot of reality TV with my wife and she
watches the [__] uh
The Apprentice Donald Trump
this is what I learned anybody who uses
that expression uh lead follow will get
out of the way right there they're
always a [__] [__]
and they're always it's they're
basically saying like [__] it I want you
to do everything my way
that's such a [__]
expression lead follow or get out of the
way I don't know who came up with that
but it was instantly on t-shirts and I
never saw anybody remotely intelligent
with the t-shirt that said lead follow
and get out of the way
it's just that classically I don't know
I know how to do [__]
lead follow get out of the way [__]
iron zaring was saying that
this is how pathetic my life was I was
watching iron Zarin on uh it was my dog
by the way I am zaring on [__]
The Apprentice
and he had a company his team had to
come up with a jingle for some sort of
new [__] Budweiser that they wanted
to
promote uh
down in the Caribbean
so he decides he's going to come up with
a jingle
it's between him and Johnny Damon so you
know the song's gonna be good right
and he comes up with like uh you know
drink [__] bud why is it
just it's La Cucaracha they're looking
at him and he like he's like I gotta get
away from you guys because you're
singing other stuff I need to go over
here and create and he comes back with
new lyrics
for La Cucaracha
right
he [__] he he [__] vanilla iced it
and then they're like dude that's La
Cucaracha we can't use that
and he got all [__] pissy
so
we got to use something else or whatever
and he just kept saying lead follow or
get or get out of the way
so the the project manager finally looks
at him she goes I am leading and he goes
well you got to delegate she goes I am
delegating I need you to shut the [__]
up
that was great and he got all mad
he got mad and then with time for them
to present it to Donald Trump he
half-asseded he didn't sing along he was
a big [__] baby
how can you be 50 years old to be that
big of a [__] baby that just was
Unreal you're gonna pout
the [__] pouts at 50.
I didn't get my way what did they take
your [__] pail and shovel
gives a [__]
let somebody else write the song and if
it sucks they're gonna get fired put
your heart and soul into it and he
didn't he acted like a [__] and you know
what he got himself [__] booted right
back to Beverly Hills
poor bastard you know if he was 10 years
younger he would have got the good hair
plugs
you know he would have he got those late
90 ones I'm gonna tell you those little
rough one you know
um what am I doing here
I met a girl six months ago all right
here we go lead follower get out of the
way right all right
now a few weeks ago
she said that she doesn't even flirt
which seems seemed very odd
yeah yeah she's already like she's let
me just recap this she's a real lady and
she Prides herself on being honest and
loyal a few weeks ago she said she
doesn't even flirt which seemed very odd
a few days later I heard her giggling
and being very flirty with this guy she
studies with I confronted her about this
and she said this is how she always
talks to him and I'm overreacting I let
it go since I always sometimes flirt
with other girls when she's not around
this week she's going on vacation with
her colleagues this guy is also going oh
the same guy oh Jesus
I brought up the vacation subject and
mentioned that in trips
that I have been as a single guy there
was a lot of sex and partying
she says that they don't do that and
tries to change the subject
let me guess is she going to Hedonism
down on the island there wherever the
[__] that goes down uh she says I don't
think
that she is cheating by Phil that she is
hiding something she also doesn't seem
very attracted to me lately even those
she says so what's your take on this one
what do you think about flirting uh
thanks and go [__] yourself
um I think you're with a lying sack of
[__]
who's a sociopath and they're saying all
the right [__] things
um
and it's also somebody that is hasn't
found who they want to be with and
they're afraid to be alone so they just
get with people
and when the initial attraction wears
off they
rather than break up they just keep
[__] lying and I never knowingly
intentionally lied I think you have to
listen to your gut here I think she's I
think this is the tip of the iceberg
this is only six months in she's going
on a [__] vacation with other
colleagues dude six months in if this
chick was into you she'd want to go on
vacation with you
she wants to go on vacation with this
[__] creep she caught her flirting
with after she said she doesn't flirt
when you didn't even give her [__] about
flirting she went out of her way to say
she doesn't flirt
give me a [__] break
hey I'm a really honest and loyal person
oh by the way I don't do heroin
why why did you just bring that up oh
you know I'm just putting it out there I
don't believe in it so you know all the
spoons are bent
uh that's just my gut the way you
presented it too by the way you might
have left some stuff out but the way you
presented it I think she's I think she's
a [__] liar
uh
all right P.S thank you for sharing your
honest Insight you funny bastard I love
the advice on life and women I also
don't trust Banks oh that's nice all
right well I don't trust your girlfriend
how about that what do you saying what
do you say there huh what do you say
there
um
you know what's funny about that and if
she actually did cheat
and you confronted her about it on one
of these [__] TV shows that they
would actually still they would still
somehow blame the guy
you know what I mean
I love that [__] like oh
they actually there's an article
somewhere on the internet I saw it you
know those things that they try to just
get you to click on it and it always
works for me you know the top 10 bad
celebrity nose jobs
the top 10 [__] gangster movies of
all time blah blah blah blah they had
the top 10 reasons women cheat right so
I looked it up in eight of the reasons
were the guy's fault
It's the funniest [__] [__] ever
oh another movie I saw a little bit of
remember that movie monster with
Charlize Theron
um
that that movie is one of the most
sexist [__] movies of all [__]
time but it'll never be called on it
because it's it's going in the other
direction
the fact that that is a movie about a
serial killer is it's
like when you look at movies about
serial killers like the Jeffrey Dahmer
one the Henry portrait of a serial
killer they are they are [__]
they are monsters right this [__]
movie despite the fact it was called
Monster it was a goddamn love story and
they Justified so much of her killing to
the point when she finally gets busted
it's this big emotional moment of when
her her lover is is gonna betray her and
rather out on the stands and it's her
you know
Charlie's character is sitting there
crying she's saying with her eyes like
it's okay baby I understand do you know
how [__] infuriated I would be
if I was a relative one of the actual
victims of that absolute [__] lunatic
serial killer
they almost made her a [__] hero
I mean I was waiting for the Sally Field
moment where she just stands up and
holds uh union now is you know for other
[__] female serial killers
it was ridiculous I don't know I don't I
don't have any uh
I don't know I'm getting very
extra jaded as I get older and I I I'm
giving a [__] less about people's
complaints because I'm finding they
never complain for other people they're
always bitching for themselves right
like take the Oscars
women got up there right and they
complained that they don't get paid
enough and blah blah blah blah blah now
why are they complaining
are they complaining because it's unfair
or are they complaining because it's
unfair and it's happening to them
you know what I mean
which is the reason why guys aren't
complaining about it because they don't
give a [__] about it because it's not
happening to them
but that doesn't make women better
people because women don't give a [__]
about the [__] that's happening the guys
have you ever seen a woman out there
that gives a [__] that there's yet
another [__] man
standing in a bay window looking out
seeing a FedEx or a UPS truck pulling up
as he's just sitting there having a mini
heart attack thinking in his head Jesus
Christ what the [__] did she buy now
she's spending all my [__] money what
the [__] could she have possibly bought
now she's spending it faster than I can
make it
you know what about that Financial
dynamic
do they ever bring that up have you ever
seen a woman stick up for a guy in that
[__] situation
why would they
they don't have time they have their own
[__] problems so that's how I view it
oh is that what's happening to you that
sucks for you
uh
I don't really feel that but it's just
it's just fun to annoy people sometimes
um all right let's plow ahead here
I do I mean look obviously I feel like
people should make
the same amount you know if you do the
same [__] job
all right but you know when you're also
completely [__] that same group of
people over that you're bitching about
in a hundred other [__] areas of life
and you choose to Overlook at it
Overlook it you know what I mean
maybe guys make more money so we can
afford to [__] get a one-bedroom
apartment after you keep the [__]
house during the divorce maybe you ever
think maybe that's why we make more from
per movie
I don't know just for anyways in general
just watching people complaining about
being in movies is is something [__]
hilarious to me there's just something
about I I'll be ever since I went to
India it's just over when I listen to
myself complain there's always in the
back of my head I just think of some of
the [__] that I saw there and it all
just becomes funny to me not in a
disrespectful way to India but like
laughing at myself that what my
complaints are
you know when I pretend to be a cowboy I
don't make as much as you do
no what size is your Mansion
um
fat shaming help
hey there Billy back on the wagon I am
back on the wagon I mean I had a couple
of [__] I had a glass of wine last night
but I have not been boozing
this is not what a good boy I've been
Paul verzi
the great Paul verzi
was at my house and I watched him smoke
a Cuban cigar and I did not smoke one
with them and by the way he saw the
rebuild downstairs and he gave it rave
reviews
rave reviews
right I'll tell you right now I will
[__] put my downstairs bathroom I
will put this bathroom up against any
[__] bathroom in a five mile radius
all right that's saying something in La
there's a lot of [__]
super talented people out here that they
have they got bathroom money all right I
am a dancing monkey level
all right so
I took my dancing monkey money and I put
it into a [__] I tell you right now
this is not a day
it's not a [__] day it's the greatest
[__] thing ever
everybody thinks you put a bathroom in
for the brunch they don't [__] get
you put a steam shower in it's [__]
over
it's unreal
it's unreal the only miss missing from
it is and then in that steam it's just a
[__] a [__] gorgeous masseuse
walks through it you know and finishes
you off with a handy wouldn't that be
[__] phenomenal
can you imagine how how much more
forgiving the business world would be if
every man's day started that way oh
just don't understand all but the church
church is against it can't have that
happen can you imagine that
you know then you spray a little
Eucalyptus in the air afterwards it's
it's just who's fighting on the subway
nobody
and if elected every man gets his steam
shower and a handy to start the business
day all right fat shaming hey there
Billy back on the wagon I love the
podcast and also want to form with you
and Joey
roses I was supposed to hang out with
roses the other night I was too sick man
I [__] love that son of a [__]
um
I'm 6'1 and used to weigh 370 pounds and
now I'm down to 219 pounds you're
goddamn right you are good for you
dude that's [__] insane
that is 151 pounds my math is correct my
math is correct
wow man
if that that thing that I overheard in a
bar that says if you're [__] every
pound of fat is five miles of
capillaries that's like 605 miles you
just took off
of road that you [__] hard has to
pump every time it goes whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa that's [__] phenomenal I
said took me a little more than a year
to lose that much and you were a big
help with that your podcast makes
working out fun after all what could be
more fun than old Billy boys screaming
about nerds or the government more than
that your fat shaming always makes me
work a little bit harder and I had never
noticed the way I'd get derailed by
sugar and salt combo that you frequently
talk about uh for a functionally
illiterate angry head case you dropped
quite a bit of knowledge my friend I'm
telling you wait look I do the same
thing everybody else does I [__]
yo-yo up and down but I keep it within a
20 mile 20 mile a 20 pound
thing like I went back up to a buck 84s
down to 168 that's my wheelhouse 168 172
and went all the way back up to like
[__] a buck 84. and I'm disgusted
with myself and uh
I'm back down to uh
what is it like one uh 178 179 so I
dropped five pounds and this is what I
do I just
I just immediately I I
um I actually will go to the gym because
there if I just get on a [__]
elliptical
all right for 45 minutes and then do the
five minute cool down I just start doing
that every [__] day and it [__]
sucks for the first three days
the first three days and that first
[__] night
when you stop eating around five or six
and you just had a protein with a salad
and then you just crushing waters for
the rest of your night okay but you got
that sugar and salt
you're [__] addicted to it because
you've been eating it
it's gonna get some ice cream get a
burger order a pizza
go make yourself some eggs you just have
to fight through that so like I'm on it
right now so what I do is I have uh I
have celery and turkey slices
and even then a lot of that turkey
slices will have a lot of salt in it so
I kind of limit that but I just uh I'll
put a little peanut butter on a [__]
the piece of celery just shove those
things down you I mean [__] eating
celery is like eating air
and all you got to do is just make it
through the first night and the next
night is way easier as far as the food
thing goes but cardio sucks for three
days for me and then after that then I'm
[__] addicted to it which is how I
got sick because I knew I was feeling
run down and I still went and did
another [__] 50 minutes walked out of
the gym the wind was blowing I don't got
a lot of [__] shingles on the roof
anymore and next thing you know I got
Ebola but anyways
that is a big thing is not only
acknowledging your sugar salt addiction
but understanding
how it affects you because I would think
just like everybody it affects everybody
differently but like
knowing like like the other day I was
just so I was I was trying to eat well
as long as I could through trying to
beat this cold and then finally I just
had enough and I just was like [__] this
man I just want a pizza and I ordered a
pizza
and
I remember thinking all right I'm eating
this at night this is all salt I was
going to send my salt to the [__]
roof and then tomorrow morning I'm
either gonna want more salt with a big
[__] eggs and sausages and that [__]
or I'm gonna go the other direction and
for some reason like I don't know why I
just feel like I want a waffle because I
ate a whole [__] [__] to the night
before
and it's literally it's like people who
[__] drink booze because they did too
much coke and you're trying to even
yourself off and what you really need to
do is just wake up knowing that you're
going to be craving those things and you
plow through it and you just make the
oatmeal instead and you shovel that [__]
down and within three spoonfuls
your body will start to [__] level
out and you'll re-remember that oh food
is supposed to energize me not drag me
down to the [__] mat and if you can
remember that
for me anyways that's how I was able to
keep I like I've gone down to about 68
like probably
four times since I moved out to LA
and this time I stayed within 168 a buck
for almost a year year and a half and I
used to when I would get down it took me
like six months to get down to that
level and then the second I got down to
that level I would reward myself with
the [__] cheeseburger and I would
like hey I've been sober six months let
me go shoot up some heroin to [__]
celebrate you do I'm doing the exact
same thing
and then you just [__] you're right
back you know chasing the dragon man and
then I would just
I Think Jesus Christ you could put it
back on you know six months take it off
put it back on in six weeks and I would
uh I would fight it but it would take me
like you know two and a half months
gotta be right back to a bucket like the
most depressing [__] number that
second number is when I see that eight I
I just I just refuse to [__] be above
a buck 80.
um with my build and everything so I'm
at least back down to you know 179 178
or something I'm gonna start working out
again tomorrow going right back on the
[__] elliptical and uh
I'm gonna try to have the discipline
this time to actually get a truly
like try to get my six-pack back one
last [__] time before I slide into
50.
just the level of discipline and the
understanding of nutrition that I'm
gonna have to have I really want to
[__] do it and I told you I'm gonna
do this bit I'm so sick of [__]
people who book movies and then they get
upset that [__] Hollywood tells them
to work out
it's it's [__] ridiculous it's like
you're gonna be in a [__] movie and
then the people are going to put a mil
millions of dollars into this thing
they're trying to not lose money they're
trying to get their money back
you know I'm not giving anybody I know
it's hard to lose weight for other
people it's harder but for you to
[__] complain that somebody wants you
to look good in a movie or to look your
best
it once again it's [__] ridiculous so
um
those people that you know
[__] Brad Pitt's in his 50s the guy
still has
you know
abs like the level of dedication that is
and [__] you he's got his own personal
chef I don't give a fight a personal
chef and be like make me some water man
I mean I would
what's he gonna say no
telling you it's a [__] discipline
and I don't have it I have the
discipline to get to within about eight
pounds of it and then I just I give in
to like the uh Hey man I'm like I'm a
buck 68 I'm like 17 pounds away from
where the [__] I just was
gonna have a burger
I'm gonna have a [__] bud tall with
this bird I dude I go off the rails it's
the worst so this time I'm gonna try and
uh
I'm gonna try to see this one through
which is why I'm saying this out loud so
because I figure you guys will be
checking in in a month or so to see how
I'm doing and give me [__] if I don't or
Heckle me on the road
it is fatty freckles whatever the hell
are you gonna say so anyways let's get
back to this guy
uh anyways I still need to lose another
20 pounds or so but I'm less worried
about that than I am with gaining it all
back this is where I need some more help
from old freckles there oh you know what
I think I just brought it up here I was
hoping you could give me some fat
shaming on the podcast that I could use
for inspiration if I start to game some
of the weight back basically if you
could just give me some version of
self-talk in the mirror when you start
to gain weight that would be amazing
uh uh as always go [__] yourself hey
this is what you do
like you know how much work it took you
you know what I would do I would write
down
I would write down the amount of months
I would write the amount of days the
amount of hours
and right down to the minutes
that you had to work to get down and
then just write just something to
motivate yourself
you know are you going to give it you're
going to give it all back you stupid
[__]
you know don't give it back don't
and you know what happens you're going
to put that on your wall or on your
bathroom mirror and this is what's going
to happen all right that's going to
motivate you for about six days
and then what's going to happen is it's
going to be it's going to be a part of
you brushing your teeth and it's not
going to hold the same meaning
so what you have to do is you have to
constantly be updating that
all right and you basically you got to
get yourself into the [__] mindset
like you're not you're not giving it
back all right so this is what I would
do
okay
there's gonna be holidays there's going
to be birthdays there's going to be you
know the night out or whatever
okay
but this is what you got to do I if I
would weigh myself every morning
so you don't you don't [__] not weigh
yourself
you know for months on end because
that's all of a sudden how you get 40
pounds 40 pounds behind the [__]
eight ball right
you weigh yourself every day
and if you went out and you know you ate
bad or whatever you decided to treat
yourself all right you're gonna be a
couple pounds over okay then you gotta
have discipline like I gotta get back
down to where the [__] I was and then
you have to have a number that is it's
just unacceptable like with me it's a
buck 80 unacceptable when I see that
eight it's [__] over I don't give a
[__] if it's Thanksgiving tomorrow well
who's gonna do I'm [__] eating
Thanksgiving but like it's it's done
um
what did you say your weight was here
you were three seven so now you're down
to 219.
all right
um so I would just say
when that second number is three that's
it that's it shut it down
shut it down and I'm telling you give
yourself that small of a [__] window
you got that small of a [__] Journey
Back
and what happens is as you know I I have
friends who have weight issues what
happens is is when they start putting it
back on that self-loathing I [__]
hate myself I [__] hate myself and
they you know they just
haven't learned that skill yet
to just [__] grab that demon by the
throat and [__] choke slam it and
just just turn it back around before you
go 100 miles in the wrong direction
and now you got to go 100 back that's a
two and a mile trip you can get 10 miles
down the [__] road turn it right back
to 20 miles no big deal
all right so
you just really have to be like listen
like for me to sit there and act like
I'm gonna be 219 for the rest of my
[__] life and never go up a little
bit or maybe go down a little bit is
[__] nuts
um
and for me to act like I'm never gonna
[__] have a piece of pie or you know
some comfort food is is ridiculous but
you just have to have like those be
special things that you do
and you have to learn how to live at
that weight
and I would actually now that you're
down to 219 whatever you did I would
also be always looking for some new way
to work out
you know a [__] boxing gym a hike
bike riding swimming anything you can do
because the same way that note on your
on your [__] bathroom mirror just
becomes part of your day and you you
you just get bored
um if you get bored with your workout
that gets dangerous
because you know you don't you never get
bored eating you just there's always you
know
you know it's funny you always go oh
Jesus what what kind of Tootsie Rolls
are these let me try these you're always
doing that you got to do the same thing
with like your [__] your workouts
there I'm done [__] preaching all
right this podcast is getting
ridiculously long dude that really that
actually what you just did is is inspire
me to go to the [__] gym tomorrow man
good for you dude that's what that's an
I've never had to try to lose weight for
over or for over a year
um that's unbelievable so dude you work
that [__] hard man you can't do that
you can't give that back you just can't
you can't and you have to keep reminding
yourself in a new way all right
make yourself proud don't [__] yourself
over all right sleazy douche
I built this guy's from Scotland or he's
a [__] pirate long time listener love
your [__] saw you both times in Sydney
please help all right maybe you said
Scott from Sydney I don't know
babies like Bond Scott right
ah [__] all right this is [__] [__]
he grew up with my girlfriend this is
why I love Australia what a way to start
a [__] thing
this is [__] [__] he grew up with my
girlfriend as The Lovable sleazy guy
that everyone tolerates ugh gotta hate
that dude
that's just that's just insert that's
just so and so that's how he is they say
so recently
he commented on a photo of my girlfriend
leaning forward and unintentionally
showing some cleavage on Facebook and I
can't stop thinking about wanting to
slap him
all he wrote uh was Jesus but what kind
of [__] think it's okay to comment
on someone's ladies in a uh someone
else's lady in a public forum any idea
on how I can satisfy my desire to write
this situation without making it too
uncomfortable for my girl uh thanks and
go [__] yourself
um
all right well first things first
I think your assessment of this person
everybody knows this person uh secondly
I don't know how you know how your
girlfriend accidentally leans forward
and unintentionally shows too much
cleavage this wasn't a video somebody
else took that was shot live this is a
photo I'm guessing she uploaded it so
she was all right with it
how do you accidentally oops is that my
ball bag
I now I have to upload it you know what
I mean
um
I don't understand why uh why this
person is uh in her life
or in anybody's life
um there's a bunch of different ways you
can go with this you can go uh
I don't know what do you do I mean I I
want you to say something to the guy but
I don't think it's going to work though
I mean if this is a movie you walk up
and you slap him in the face
right
and then your girlfriend appreciates you
and then uh reciprocates uh physically
but we know that's not how the world
Works don't we
so
um
and we also know you can't you can't
blame your girlfriend
so uh what do you do Jesus Christ This
is a [__] Quagmire
I thought this was going to be easy this
is goddamn quicksand here so recently
commented on the photo
um
you know he's a [__] jerk off why
waste your [__] time this is what you
do you know what this is what you do you
just put that in the old memory bank
right
the next time you're out there playing
Aussie rule footballs and he's on the
other [__] team right did I say
footballs Aussie rule fuzzy rules right
maybe I'll stop texting me that was a
Freudian slip about [__] kicking them
right in the balls uh you take them out
that's what you do oh you just wait you
you pick your [__] this might be one
of those ones where you lay back
okay you pick your [__] spot
and uh you know when the time is [__]
right you make your point you're looking
right in the eye and you you [__] you
make your point
who knows if he pushes you you get to
slap him you don't look like an [__]
right was that all right
I don't know for some reason that guy
really [__] annoyed me I might have
given you bad advice because I kind of
gotta let my emotions get the best of me
there all right let me read another
couple of [__] uh ads here that we
could wrap this thing up
um yeah that's what I would do I would
bank that one
I would bank that one
um
worst case scenario I would ask
your girlfriend like why is this jerk
off in your social Social Circle
and just hear her out be like all right
why why what's wrong uh because I I
think he's not a good person I think
he's a dirtbag
like why do you say that well because
he's commenting about your boobs
oh well that was just blow and just be
like all right
let me just leave it at that
you said you think to her that whatever
ah that sucks that if you [__] slap
him in a bar you establish a motive with
her from the conversation that you know
she's not going to forget
that's a tough one you might have to go
[__] psycho on this one you might
have to just it's never good when you
keep it to yourself ah [__] it keep it
to yourself
just don't [__] do physical harm to
them but a nice [__] slap a nicely
timed [__] slap
that could be a good thing
next time he says something oh dude that
would be hilarious the next time he's
out and everybody's sitting around all
coupled up and he's just the [__]
jerk off right and he makes some sort of
rude comment
slap him across the face not hard
well you'd like actually do physical
damage just slap him in the face like
you would a kid
and then you point right in his face and
just be like hey
behave yourself like whatever a parent
would say to like an eight-year-old
and just leave it at that
and even if everybody thinks you're a
psycho at the end of the day you still
did it
and you know what even if he is a [__]
he's gonna watch his [__] mouth
around you
that's more [__] belittling than
getting punched in the face if someone
just [__] just you know what if you
just grab them you know your mother used
to grab you on either side of your
cheeks and she'd [__] you know she'd
cry I can't I'm not explain it she just
pinching both of your cheeks and then
you [__] fish Puck it up you fish
your lips Puck it up like fish lips
he's [__] grabbed him she'd wag her
finger right in your face give him one
of those
except a real parental and humiliating
oh
what's up buddy
huh
it's [__] dog I really hung out with
you for the last four days and I
realized that you sleep 12 hours a night
in four hours during the day
you get up to to go to the bathroom or
eat or to come up on the bed and be pet
and that's it
you know what you got no goals
it's [__] perfect man all right uh so
yes we Have No Bananas that's the name
of the tour the uh the Billy Bible Belt
tour
we had the Billy red state tour
um keeps staying with the Billy name
Billy Bible Belt I thought about Billy
Bob's Bible Belt some of themself and no
Billy Bible belts oh freckled Fury is
coming through the South I thought about
Berman's March you know now I can't do
that because that's gonna I can't rub
into their faces that not only did we
win the civil war but we committed war
crimes
you know was that a war crime well we
won right well that's it
um I did a night of too many stars so
look for that I did a little bit of
stand up on that in uh Martha Stewart
just stared at me the entire time
which was uh was unsettling
you know when you see somebody famous in
the crowd you want them to at least
acknowledge that you're there maybe
laugh
because you think that they know
something when they have a [__]
Empire
she wasn't feeling it
um all right Jon Stewart hosts who's the
greatest [__] guy ever in this
business so in tribute of Him in all his
great work that he did on The Daily Show
this is your Moment of Zen this is my
dog getting a back rub
thank you
[Music]